i just love
listening to him and his watch um the
number of uh different play on words of
the word love of unc's player named love
was really uh enjoyable and then you
just add in a touch of the spinarkl and
it really is just a terrific listen he
is the broadcaster
iron eagle back here in the rich eisen
show hey you and i
you uh have clearly had a lot of proud
peacock representation already yes peter
king and mike florio and now i'm kind of
an unofficial peacock yes sir we're the
saint peter's run so it's it's my honor
and my pleasure to be on the program
you're peacock adjacent after i've been
calling that game yes
i'm gonna put that on my business card
man i thought you know i i was you know
obviously hoping for a better game but
unc is just quite a remarkable story in
its own right what uh what was your
front row seat literal figurative uh
view of it ian yeah we uh
we obviously went in with the idea that
maybe these guys
just don't feel any fear or any
stress and any intimidation going
against blue blood programs what they
did against kentucky the win over murray
state that was mid major against mid
major and then the victory over purdue
that was really a shocker based on the
fact that the boilermakers had time to
prepare for them had tape to watch how
to feel for what they were going to do
and just had so much raw size and still
saint peter's found a way to win
we
we saw dan gavitt just before the game
got underway he made a great point when
we asked his opinion on the matchup
and he said
unc although this is not a normal
role for them
they've kind of had that underdog
mentality the last few weeks they were
on the bubble they finished the acc
season strong they obviously got the win
at duke at cameron and then the showing
in the acc tournament
and
that mentality probably put them in a
better frame of mind than kentucky or
purdue when they played saint peter's
because so much was expected of them
and
both teams thought they had a chance to
win a national championship so in this
particular matchup
they may have benefited saint peter's by
going against ucla
then
north carolina in just the idea that
they could still maybe sneak up on
someone despite everything they
accomplished unc they've already been
through the roller coaster of emotions
this year and they're just getting
stronger and stronger as they go i i
thought they were
they were lights out they were money
they were impressive from the word go
they looked like one of the best teams
in the country and that game against
duke i mean my gosh
you can't make it up you cannot make up
that matchup i mean i said at the top of
the show it's like packers bears in the
nfc championship game yankees red sox
and the alcs this is it it's go time
unreal yeah it's a dream matchup and
it's funny when these things come about
and you start getting the the notes and
the nuggets that are connected to it
you do a double take so i'm doing my
prep and you would just assume that you
know this already being a sports fan
but they have never played in the ncaa
tournament you write that down on your
prep sheet you say how how is that
possible with the history between these
two programs with the legacy of
greatness you would just assume
somewhere along the line they would have
played in a sweet 16 in an elite eight
in a final four in a national
championship game no they were only in
the same final four once 1991. didn't
play one another that was of course the
duke unlv semi-final match-up the
retribution game and it was kansas the
remnants of the danny and the miracle
squad that played north carolina and the
other semi kansas
advanced and we know duke advanced duke
won the national championship that was
the first of many for mike
so
the fact that it's happening now in
coach k's final year that it was
unexpected from a unc standpoint and
then add that additional layer of what
happened in coach k's final home game as
a coach the way unc took over the game
embarrassed duke at the end and all of
the alums former players that are
standing there and had to watch it with
the rest of the crowd dumbfounded
it just
it just adds a whole other vibe to this
semi-final matchup it's
it's nirvana it's college basketball
nirvana this is the kind of stuff you
root for and so yeah i guess when you
think about it ayan uh that if if a team
is like if duke and carolina are both
you know seated one or two
in in
different regions
it stands to reason like they they they
wouldn't meet right just be for merely
unless unless they get to the same final
four so you got one now seated eighth it
would make sense that duke and carolina
could play each other at some point in
the sweet 16 but the fact is that
they're coming from different parts of
the bracket is unbelievable and as you
pointed out the cameron indoor setup i'm
kind of sitting here wondering like
if that gives unc more confidence in a
game like this or duke has a revenge
angle they normally wouldn't have you
know what i mean to erase that those
kids who might be
terribly upset and saw coach k sort of
admonish the crowd for cheering when
he's like that that was a bad
performance i'm wondering if these kids
will now use that as a clarion call to
erase that by winning this game you know
excellent excellent question
you know the other part of the equation
is the fact that the committee for all
of these years i think they've tried to
avoid having duke and unc play in early
rounds because of the history between
the two because they're coming from the
same conference they really do make an
effort to try to avoid those kinds of
matchups early because the tournament is
supposed to be about
other matchups new matchups
new
rivalries that emerge based on the ncaa
tournament everything you laid out is
100 true
you get to this stage and i think each
team probably has their own narrative of
of what it is that's motivating them at
this point the disrespect that unc was
feeling the fact that hubert davis was
being questioned early in his coaching
tenure after replacing a legend in roy
williams they got crushed by kentucky it
was an embarrassing nationally televised
game by 20 plus points they lost to
purdue rather handily there were these
these little markers along the way that
that led us to believe that north
carolina wasn't a legitimate team this
year and yet
they came together and found chemistry
at the most important time and then for
duke all the expectations you're looking
at future nba stars on the team and you
start questioning well maybe it's just
not the right mix or
maybe they just don't have
that that fire lit inside them that was
the concern
watching that unc duke game at cameron
nobody seemed to want it and i know they
wanted it for mike
but they couldn't seem to make it happen
on the court there there were shots
being passed up in the final three and a
half minutes and nobody really stepped
forward and all that has changed in the
ncaa tournament whether that flipped the
switch or that opened their eyes or they
just needed to get past that moment with
all of those great duke players in
attendance and and it spooked them out
who knows whatever it is they're playing
at such an exceptionally high level and
they did get tested it's not like
they've plowed through the first
four rounds of the tournament we have
seen them pushed a little bit so to me
that's a really good sign for duke as
well that they come in
battle tested for this final four and
everything that's going to come with it
which is a great deal of media attention
they're they're going to feel the weight
of the final four and coach k's legacy
talked about for the next five days in
at infinitum so uh how many games of st
peters did you did you have just the one
i had all of them you know i i was like
the unofficial soundtrack
and let me tell you it was glorious it
was a tremendous story
the first game against kentucky
you know how this works rich there's
phases to an upset when you look at the
anatomy of an ncaa tournament upset the
first phase is all right can they hang
is this going to be 16-2
at at the end of six minutes in the game
or
is it going to be
9-6 in that first timeout and and they
absorb the first punch so that's the
first phase they pass that loud and
clear the second phase is well can they
really compete can this be a competitive
game is this going to spill over into
the second half and it's a one
possession two possession game and are
they going to give the higher seed
something to think about something to be
nervous about and then the third phase
is can they actually win because we've
seen a bunch of lower seeds
push
a blue blood to the brink of elimination
but then the future nba standout takes
over or the ball bounces their way and
uh the the lower seed is left four lawn
and and walking off the court thinking
what could have been and they passed all
three of those tests that final test
overtime against kentucky you just
assume right oh the wildcats will take
over they got 10 000 fans in indy
they're gonna feel the buzz of the crowd
and and who they are is going to emerge
and the number two seed will advance
they'll have been pushed but they'll
survive it they didn't saint peters
never
blinked it was
wild to watch and then to draw murray
state in the second round where they
thought oh wait we can play with these
guys
this isn't out of the realm for
for the peacocks to advance against the
team that also has been questioned about
where they fit into the grand landscape
uh so it really was a blast and
uh you you could feel it building where
people started googling
where is saint peter's universe
i think most people had no id they're
filling out a bracket like oh yeah
kentucky st peters
virginia
wisconsin where is that it's new jersey
it's jersey city and rich if you drove
right now through jersey city yes and
pass by the university
you may miss it there might have been
over you're like wait is that it
that one right there that building yeah
that's it
amazing i thought i saw a tweet where
that kentucky might have players
collectively
uh have a collective you know nil
hall more than the the budget of the
basketball program
i would not doubt that
that's what i saw i saw some other
tweets that that talked about the
finances john calipari is one of the
highest paid coaches in college
basketball he certainly earned it with
what he's done through the years but i
believe his salary is in the range of
eight million dollars and i believe the
entire sports budget at st peters might
be 7.5 million dollars
tell me you had an opportunity to do a
promo for a show on tnt and say that
they they know drum a during one of
those games
because you didn't have anything rich
every one of our games is the first time
in my career yes every one of our games
was on cbs we had nine games wow all of
them were on cbs so there was no
dram a there was more abashola i had to
make a choice and i read the card that's
what i did but still so iron are you
saying you i think you made cbs history
then if i'm not mistaken because i've at
least tied a record well i just don't i
don't know if nance has ever done a
promo for cash nasty
house of highlights i mean the way the
way you did the house of highlights cash
nasty promo
was i wrote it down even i even wrote it
down
because i i was left so impressed by how
you just weaved it all together yeah
on cbs the scary part is i know we're
half joking here but i do care it
matters to me because you're a pro i
read these correctly and i make either
the sponsor happy or the network happy i
don't know when that was embedded in my
brain that that was important in this
job but trust me i was getting texts
during
and i'm shocked you didn't reach out
i thought you would during a couple of
weeks
and some of them were like you have no
idea what you're reading right
and it's true i i had a little to no
idea but i sold it damn well yes you did
you i bought it i bought it
um figuratively i don't know if i'll get
the cash nasty house highlights um
i don't know who do we know who cash
nasty is do we know yet have we
wow tj or even you're shaking your head
we have no idea okay very good because i
honestly i thought it was like a new
show on cbs or something like that might
be with g-unit i'm not sure all special
an all-new cash nasty um before i let
you go sir uh do i eagle here on the
rich either show do we see ben simmons
soon what do we see in uh brooklyn with
ben simmons what do you think yeah mixed
messages it sounds like he's feeling a
little better the back issue is
legitimate and it is a disc problem and
then he was having problems down his leg
as well so whatever feeling there was in
the lower back had continued into the
lower extremities
i think they're still encouraged that
he's going to be able to play at some
point but they're running out of time
there just are not a whole lot of games
left we're talking about two weeks left
in the regular season so the big term
that we hear around the nba is the ramp
up
and this has been a very long ramp up
for ben simmons they don't believe that
it's going to be an issue integrating
him
but until you see him with kyrie with kd
with the rest of the team it's hard to
evaluate
what they're going to be the crazy part
rich
they could get clipped
in the playing round they could if they
go against a hot player or a hot team or
the circumstances
aren't to their advantage or
they could win the whole thing
the parameters are really wide right now
for this team which i think for the nba
is actually intriguing and and that's
part of the reason why you have this
playing around to get more fan bases
around the country interested in this
and create more opportunities for a team
to go on a run yeah i would proffer to
say trey young might be the last person
they'd want to see um
in the playing game part of that guy in
a one game format everything that i just
learned
and all these years of doing the ncaa
tournament yes one game yes anything can
happen
oh my goodness gracious but i mean
seth curry was a heck of an addition and
andre drummond has certainly come to the
fore right aldridge is coming back and
and i don't know there's no such thing
as a ceremonial you know first tip but
if if there was i think they'd have the
mayor of new york come and provide it
right
if there's such a thing so rather
interesting yes you know uh
i i think they still feel confident that
they can play with anybody and if they
get their team out there
in time to do this that they could go on
a run and win the whole thing but it's
hard to make that proclamation
when you just haven't seen it
consistently the phoenix sun show you
every time that they play with chris
paul without chris paul they have
championship medal now this team is
motivated highly motivated to prove that
what they're doing in the regular season
is real and it's going to translate in
the postseason the nets have had such an
odd obscure regular season
that i have no idea what the carryover
is going to be if they can just flip the
switch and and turned it on for the
playoffs they have kevin durant so
they're going to be able to compete with
anybody but can they win it can they win
four games in four straight series
amidst what has been a highly
inconsistent regular seasons
so then the last one for you is which is
the best team you've seen with your own
two eyes calling games for the the nets
who do you uh i mean i've seen the suns
in person and i'm just thoroughly
impressed with their confidence level
and
the level in which they execute and also
the coaching dynamic with the players
chris paul's leadership all of that
they've been the most impressive team
i've seen but i've seen boston playing
at a really high level the robert
williams injury is a big hit today i've
seen milwaukee play at a ridiculously
high level when everything's clicking i
saw philadelphia roll
in an impressive performance
i've seen utah play
excellent basketball
i i just think it's a it's a fun
backdrop right now in the nba that you
don't have the guarantee
team that you say that's it no one's
touching them there are enough debates
that can go on especially in the eastern
conference that uh we might see a
surprise team emerge here miami's going
through some stuff clearly yes there's
something going on there i do i did not
know that
i honestly did not know the jimmy butler
udonis haslam
eric spoelstra set to was like an oscars
preview i had no earthly idea you know
yeah that that was legit and then last
night while i got home from philadelphia
yes happen to be watching that live that
you're alluding to yes sir and
there was a moment i it didn't take long
for me but there was a moment where you
just think oh it's a bit like chris rock
hung in there
and he didn't react so yeah this must be
the bit and then
the uh the reaction after you realize
this this was well it was not a bit
you're a live tv guy so you know uh the
delay that when uh you know what a you
know what dumping out of the live uh
television feed and audio looks like and
that was one of the longest i've ever
seen last night unreal yeah and and when
you get a text right afterwards from
people are like check out the japanese
feed
everything i'm like oh wow they they
don't care they dumped nothing
you know australia too there's the
aussie rules there was uh that was quite
something
yeah good day mate i was
i was impressed
uh it was just great listening to you
and uh the rest of the crew on those
calls really just phenomenal so
entertaining so enjoyable and uh i
always appreciate you uh chiming in here
on this program yeah my my pleasure rich
jim spinarcol jamie erdahl great
teammates our whole crew uh craig silver
suzanne smith everybody just crushed it
and as you know yes spinarcol
it's like beetlejuice if you say it
three times
you disappear so don't do that
i've said it once you said it once i
think we're dimensional we're on the
razor's edge so
don't say it three times don't test face
thanks for the call i appreciate it all
right see you guys i and eagle the one
and only right here on the rich eisen
show hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here